-Our next guest
is a very funny comedian
who created and stars
in the new comedy series
"The Ms. Pat Show,"
which is streaming now on BET+.
Let's take a look.
-What's going on with you?
-You wouldn't understand.
-Why not?
-You don't care about
stuff like this.
-Like what?
-Racism.
You bought those Paula Deen pots
even after she called us
the N-word.
-Child, them pots
went from $100 to $20.
That's the best time
to buy racism,
when it's on sale.
Hell, I'm still waiting on
Rachael Ray to [bleep] up.
-Please welcome to the show
Ms. Pat.
Pat, how are you?
-Hey, how you doing?
-I'm doing really well.
So, you got into comedy
a little bit later in life.
What was it that made you decide
that comedy was the right career
for you?
-'Cause I'm a convicted felon
and it's hard to find a job.
-Okay.
-It was the only thing
that wouldn't ask me
for a criminal background
history.
So I was like, "This is for me.
Nobody care what I did
10 years ago."
-But you had --
when you started doing it,
you already had two kids,
you were married,
and when you started going out
to do comedy,
you actually were not straight
with your husband.
You told him you were going out
and taking dancing lessons?
-Yeah, until my wigs came back
smelling like weed
and cigarettes.
-[ Laughs ]
-He was like, "What type
of lessons are you taking,
coming home smelling like that?"
And I was like,
"Well, I'm a comedian."
He was like, "Please get a job.
Please get a job."
I'm like,
"No, it's something here.
They say I'm funny,
and it don't require
a criminal background history."
And I just kept going.
-Well, I'm sure he is glad
that you did.
I want to talk a little bit --
So, you grew up in Atlanta.
Based on what I've heard,
maybe a rougher part of Atlanta.
Is it true that --
I'm reading it here --
you've been shot twice
and hit by a dump truck once?
-Yeah, I was shot twice,
once in the titty and once
in the back of the head.
-[ Laughs ]
-The dump truck
came from an accident
with my first kid's father.
And, you know, I've learned
to live with a half a nipple.
Two nipples is overrated.
Nobody's ever gonna use both
of them at the same time.
-[ Laughs ]
That's a very --
-And by the time I was shot
the second time,
there was no need
for the nipple.
I didn't want to give my baby
lead poison anyway.
-Now, this show
is about your life.
It's based on the people
in your life.
How does your family feel
about you using
these personal stories?
-What are they gonna say?
I get paid.
Who's gonna stop me?
I'm the mama.
[ Laughs ]
If you don't want me to write
it, don't do it in front of me.
Nobody can stop me.
They cheering me
all the way to the bank.
-This is based on you moving
from Atlanta to Indiana.
This was a real-life move
of yours.
Did you experience culture shock
when you made that move?
-Oh, my God,
when I first got to Indiana,
they had corn everywhere.
And I've never seen corn.
I asked the Realtor, I was like,
"Why don't these people
cut they grass?"
He literally --
He pulled over and laughed at me
for 10 minutes.
He was like,
"Ma'am, that's corn."
I'm like,
"Why y'all got so much?"
And then I moved
into an apartment,
and my white neighbors
did something
my black neighbors never did.
They knocked on the door
with a chocolate cake.
And it floored me.
And I called my friend who live
in a white neighborhood,
and I was like,
"Uh, they bringing me food."
She was like, "Just eat it.
They don't want you
to break in they house."
[ Laughter ]
And so -- which --
You know,
I'm from a black community.
You don't knock on black people
door and bring them food.
That's a sign of,
you want my husband.
So that's why I was like,
"She want my husband?
We just moved here."
-Now, Pat, I heard in
the shooting of this show,
and it's never easy
to shoot a television show,
but it was
particularly hard on you
because you were
becoming dehydrated.
I have heard, Pat,
you don't like to drink water.
-I don't like water.
I grew up in the inner city
of Atlanta,
and they didn't care
what type of field trip
they took poor
little black kids to.
So they took me
to the waterwork.
And they took me on a part
where it was unprocessed
and said, "Hey, this is
how you make water."
And they scared
the crap out of me.
And then they took you
to the other side with a cup
and say,
"Take a cold glass of water."
I was like, "No,
I'm not gonna take --
I think I saw something
my brother put out there."
-[ Laughs ]
-And so I don't like water.
I mean, they scared me.
So, I mean, I can't do it.
I should do it,
but I don't like water.
But I do take a bath,
because I'm in my --
I'm over 40,
and I don't have the type of
body where you can skip a bath.
'Cause if I do, some items
are gonna start tapping on me,
"You need to go wash us, quick."
-Did you --
You know, you talked about
getting into comedy
later in life.
What were some of the jobs
you had earlier in your life?
-Oh, I used to work
at McDonald's, Target, Walmart.
I used to steal from McDonald's.
That was my side hustle.
All teenagers stole
from McDonald's, okay?
The statute of limitations
is up.
Don't come after me, McDonald's.
So that was my side hustle,
stealing from McDonald's.
[ Both laugh ]
-You -- Not only do you
have your new show,
you're gonna start touring
again, which is so exciting,
and you have a podcast,
"The Patdown,"
and you've managed to do that
through the pandemic?
-Oh, yeah, I do "The Patdown"
right there.
I have a movie theater
in the bottom of my room
and I can go down there, no wig.
They don't care how I look.
They just want me to talk, Seth.
And it's a nice little room.
I can get away from my husband
and my kids.
A lot of times the whole family
interrupt the podcast,
so I put everybody
on the podcast.
-Are you excited to get out
and start touring again?
-Yeah, you know, when you're
married to the same person,
you leave them a little while,
you come home,
you love them a little bit more.
[ Both laugh ]
I know you can't say that,
but I can say that
'cause he won't see this.
He's asleep.
He go to sleep at 5:00.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, I can imagine.
I can imagine he needs
a good night's sleep.
Hey, Pat,
congratulations on the show.
And thanks so much
for spending time with us.
It's been a delight
talking to you.
-Thank you for having me.
-"The Ms. Pat Show"
is streaming on BET+.
And for information
on stand-up tour dates,
go to mspatcomedy.com.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."